so this right over here is one way to
represent the number 37 the number 37
has a three right over here in the tens
place and so this three literally
represents three tens notice this is a
ten here this is a ten here and this is
a ten here three tens or thirty and you
see each of these tens there's one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
now the seven is in the ones place it
literally represents seven ones and you
see that right over here one two three
four five six seven so you can say that
37 37 is equal to is equal to three tens
do this in the purple color it's equal
to three tens plus plus seven ones plus
seven ones now what if I wanted to add
something to 37 what would 37 37 37 plus
plus to be equal to how many tens and
how many ones well think about it we're
now going to add two so we're adding two
ones so we're going to add one and two
so now we still have three tens so let's
write that down so we still have three
tens but now we have a different number
of ones we now have one two three four
five six seven eight nine we now have
nine ones or another way to think about
it seven ones plus two ones is nine ones
so let me write that down
so plus nine ones or another way to
think about it is 37 30 let me do this
right the same way 37 37
plus two is equal to three tens so I
could write this as 30 and then nine
ones is equal to 39 and that's exactly
what we have here we have 30 this is the
three tens and then we have nine ones
which is 39 39 squares